question good have you ever had a girl
cheat with you
as in she was cheating on somebody else
yeah yeah yeah what i've heard from guys
is like
that
getting women kind of ruined them
because they saw the awful things women
did with them
exactly that is probably the biggest
factor and it's always the girls like
you wouldn't expect is what they would
say
so i'm curious because guys always say
you can tell if she's a hoe but they'll
also say like it's always the ones you
didn't expect so
what what's which one's true
um both statements are true okay
definitely but
i feel like people get into stuff
you know
alcohol being a social lubricant
and
people just
really wanting to do bad stuff
you know
and like we were talking about earlier
men and women both like sex
so
when you have that dynamic
whatever can go wrong will go wrong
but
again
women like to be held unless until it's
accountable
so
when you're dealing with
certain women who
cheat
again they've already made it so
is happening because of somebody else
it's not happening because they want
that's what girls always say whenever
like you say she's not having sex it's
like why is just she having sex or if
she cheated well why didn't she cheat
when it's like does it matter yeah who
cares yeah unless you got like unless
you're with the not having said unless
you're sick or something but like like
sick i'm talking like
yeah like
terminal yeah right
so yeah man they always seem to be like
hurt out but it's like well for why it's
crazy because it's like you may approach
a girl
who
tells you she's in a relationship and
she seems like she's a loyal good girl
and you still talk to her and even like
a part of you doesn't even want her to
to slip
and then she does slip and give you what
you want and you're just disappointed in
her for doing it
and again that again causes trauma and
because then it's like how would you
trust
exactly because one day that's going to
be you
yeah i mean some guys kind of
it's weird because
i i almost think once a guy has slept
with a like a certain amount of girls
like it kind of ruins him too on some
extent because he can't look at women
the same yeah and
like it's almost
his lifestyle doesn't really match the
woman that he would want you know this
is why i was saying earlier that the
whole sort of
rate in good and bad sex is not
something i do because it's like
i feel like you you just get past all
that once you once you've had a certain
amount of women
like your objective is more
ego based than
chasing this sort of so-called good and
bad sex you just want to be like yeah i
managed to get her
as opposed to looking at this amazing
woman who's
backing it up like nobody else and it's
like
you know
but it's kind of it's kind of like a
double-edged sword because if you view
women as special
they don't want you
right
and so
it's like a double-edged sword okay but
then it's like the things you have to do
to not be women is special it's like
then you almost don't want that anymore
yeah
that's right i see a lot of like
playboys get older you know like i'm
like and i'm just like
are they winning i'm hugh hefner was he
winning kinda yeah i mean i would trade
my life for the life he was having yeah
do you think like who actually
questioned would men prefer that or like
a family in general
um i feel like i know i know they'd
prefer in between but if they had to
pick one if we had to pick one i
honestly feel like we would pick hugh
hefner yeah
i do i think
that i think the family thing
wait sorry can i just add a caveat so
you wouldn't pick the idea of legacy
like your your lines being passed down
being able to kind of
have
i don't know yeah honestly bro i do not
know many people in happy relationships
and i know people in relationships so
cool you've made kids
whatever but
you're
fundamentally you're not that happy and
the thought of that legacy is not what's
carrying you life is literally carrying
you you understand you have to provide
and you have to look after your family
but you're genuinely not happy
now
living that hugh hefner lifestyle
there will be moments where you think
this might get a bit boring
but then you will get strong again and
you'll have an abundance of beautiful
women to deal with
and you'll start feeling happy again i
feel you'll have more moments of
happiness than sadness
in that situation than in a family
orientation
what i said sorry i ain't pulling it i
just hi sarah sarah pull up pull up we
got 12 more hours he's not
he's not pulling up he said
i guess like i just always had a really
good example of like marriage and my
parents and like the families around us
but i'm also a woman so i know like we
view things differently yeah but
i don't know like my parents my parents
were always like the cute ones growing
up like they were always the ones that
were like holding hands and like yeah
like i don't know like doing like cute
[ __ ]
but you also know that
that is very rare like you not really
where i'm from no
like i can think of like three four i
mean i wouldn't say it's like the rule i
say it's like 50 50 where i'm from or
like
what is
like families being like happy and i
mean happy's relative so i'm not like
they're not teenager puppy like you know
like first
year of dating love but
it's like
like overall i'd say they like each
other they're happy you know that's nice
yeah that's my point it's like it's
really not
you know
so yeah i'm i'm getting huge
ish
again you have no family legacy
i'm going playboy bunny yeah yo i can't
lie to you
i'm a big family man yeah yeah cat
i'm playing on play
i picked family yeah but maybe i'd say i
date a virgin
no but that's probably on the basis that
i
that you have not i have i've never
experienced having my own family in it
and i think ideally i my mindset would
be
to like have the nuclear family and try
and see where that goes
um but
the hugh hefner lifestyle
yeah like
like i've seen it i you know i mean i've
seen it i i know what it entails i know
what it looks like at the top right not
personally but i i've seen it i've
witnessed it i've been around it it's
like
okay i know what
what it would look like yeah i have an
idea okay and therefore i'm like you
think the family would be better yeah
you think the same
vagina for 50 years would be better
i think the same
nagging mm-hmm